Dear fellow scholars. This is terminate papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér. Today,
I will attempt to tell you a glorious tale about AI based music generation.
You see there's no shortage of neural network based methods that can perform
physics, simulations, style transfer, deep fakes,
and a lot more applications where the training data is typically images or
video. If the training data for a neural network is in pure text,
it can learn about that. If the training data is way forms and music,
it can learn that to wait. Really? Yes. In fact,
let's look at two examples and then dive into today's amazing paper
in this earlier. Work by the name. Look, listen, and learn.
Two scientists at deep mind,
set out to look at a large number of videos with sound you see here that
there is a neural network for processing division and one for the audio
information. That sounds great, but what are these heat maps?
These were created by this learning algorithm and they show us which part of the
image is responsible for the sounds that we hear in the video, the hotter,
the color, the more sounds are expected from a given region.
It was truly amazing that it didn't automatically look for humans and color
red. In the heat map.
There are cases where the humans are expected to be the source of the noise.
For instance, in concerts, where in other cases,
they don't emit any noise at all. It could successfully identify these cases.
This still feels like science fiction to me.
And we covered this paper in 2017,
approximately 250 episodes ago.
You will see that we have come a long,
long way since we often say that these neural networks should try to embody
general learning concepts. That's an excellent, and in this case,
testable statement.
So let's go ahead and have a look under the hood of these vision and audio
processing neural networks. And yes, they are almost identical.
Some parameters are not the same because they have been adapted to the length
and dimensionality of the incoming data.
But the key algorithm that we ran for the learning is the same
later in 2018,
DeepMind published a followup work that looks at performances on the piano
from the masters of the past and learns to play in their style.
A key differentiating factor here was that it did not do what most previous
techniques do, which was looking at the score of the performance.
These older techniques knew what to play, but not how to play these notes.
And these are the nuances that truly make music come alive.
This method learned from raw audio wave forms, and thus could capture much,
much more of the artistic style, less listen to it. And in the meantime,
you can look at the composers. It has learned from, to produce these works.
[Inaudible].
However,
in 2019 open AI recognized that text-based music synthesizers
can not only look at a piece of score,
but can also continue it thereby composing a new piece of music.
And what's more,
they could even create really cool blends between genres listen,
as their AI starts out from the first six notes of a Chapin piece and
transitions into a pop style with a bunch of different instruments entering a
few seconds in.
[Inaudible].
Very cool. The score based techniques are a little lacking in nuance,
but can do magical genre mixing and more,
whereas the way farm-based based techniques are more limited,
but can create much more sophisticated music.
Are you thinking what I am thinking? Yes,
you have guests ride hold onto your papers because in open AI's new work,
they tried to fuse the two concepts together. Or in other words,
take a genre and artist and even lyrics as an input.
And it would create a song for us.
Let's Marvel at a few curated samples together.
The genre artists and lyrics informations will always be on the screen.
[Inaudible], you know.
Wow, I am speechless.
Love the AIB is lyrics to this has the nuance of way form based techniques
with the versatility of score based methods. Glorious.
If you look in the video description,
you will find a selection of uncurated music samples as well.
It does what it does by compressing the raw audio wave form into a compact
representation in this space.
It is much easier to synthesize new patterns after which we can decompress it
to get the output wave forms.
It has also learned to group up and cluster a selection of artists,
which reflect how the AI thinks about them.
There is so much cool stuff in here that it would be worthy of a video of its
own. Not that it currently takes nine hours to generate one minute of music.
And the network was mainly trained on Western music and only speaks English.
But, you know, as we always see around here,
two more papers down the line and it will be improved significantly.
I cannot wait to report on them, should any follow up works, appear.
So make sure to subscribe and hit the bell icon to not miss it.
What a time to be alive.
What you see here is an instrumentation of this exact paper we have talked
about, which was made by weights and biases.
I think organizing these experiments really showcases the usability of their
system weights and biases provides tools to track your experiments in your deep
learning project. Their system is designed to save you a ton of time and money,
and it is actively used in projects at prestigious labs,
such as open AI Toyota research GitHub and more.
And the best part is that if you're an academic or have an open source project,
you can use their tools for free. It really is as good as it gets,
make sure to visit them through wmb.com/papers,
or just click the link in the video description.
And you can get the freedom or today our thanks to weights and biases for their
longstanding support and for helping us make better videos for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous support. And I'll see you next time.